yeah welcome to this video playing hager
here I don't don't know the name is some
regular be three player Wow okay yeah
you can you can do that so it's similar
to jump off scale okay let's just get on
with development it's a very very solid
set up of course for for white
can I exchange this this bishop on the
phone yeah not sure if I want to
committee
he's going for see 493 and stuff like
that now maybe I can exchange the bishop
so
yeah but with Bishop before
maybe I can irritate him a bit with
night before I cannot irritate him a bit
with the night before ok he instantly
replied maybe L correctly correctly so
yeah don't like this position too much
night before he goes just 93 and it
didn't didn't amount to much okay maybe
I can get in pawn to e4 then night
before to d3 or something now I don't
know probably the Sforza good too yeah I
don't know plate a bit too superficially
or something hardly the idea of others
faucets to play b5 getting play here in
the center b5 trying to provoke now he
plays it just like that it's a
difference of course I'm but still okay
now he wants to go Ruby one and a ticket
ok Queen asset XO needs to react first
ok and now it's giving me some tempe
don't know why
yeah this is snow no finer and this fine
night if for I have have this myth this
is good if it takes I take with the
night and then this this night is
stranded and yeah and this I thought
wouldn't wouldn't be playable because of
Queen B 5 and now he resigns a phalanx
and V 2 eggs and curtains I hope
yeah I think that just two pieces
hanging and I don't know when how we
like resign yes it's no way to defend
them it was it was very bad already here
but then he played a serious this is
really a strange move giving me this
move with the temple that I want to play
anyway anyway sorry mm-hmm NTA can also
just retreat this is this is just giving
me this this game basically or he must
play a very very ugly moves like 91 or
so so it's ugly but it's not losing
probly instantly like it's this is fine
with the FR and so on but so I'm not a
win okay thanks for watching